covering a half acre with hanging
flowers the oldest known wisteria in
japan is the centerpiece of this
brilliantly pastel colored flower park
[Music]
located in tochiki japan just over an
hour train ride from tokyo is ashikaga
flower park the park spans 23 acres and
is home to more than 350 wisterias and
other flowers
the colors vary depending on the
flowering season from pinks and purples
to yellows and whites
some features of the park include the
wisteria tunnel and floating gardens but
the pride and joy of ashikaga flower
park is the great miracle wisteria
the 140 year old sprawling tree is
located in a place of pride right in the
center of the park
after nightfall the site is lit up so
these draping flowers can be seen at all
hours
the vivid yellow wisteria begins
blooming at the start of may and is the
only one of its kind in japan
the park is a year-round attraction with
seasonal plants that creates an
ever-changing sense of magnificence as
nature puts on a show
[Music]
you